[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale
j'ai quand un journal oublierez nouvelle
j'espère qu'elles seront tous à ce que
tel voyage remporté à aubenas et barzi
bave sur qu'outil des petits commérages
eu de très grosses le petit et cours de
la forêt ces intrus vrai il y à toutes
les informations à chaque nouvelle
édition on n'a jamais de déception ça
vous le découvrirez dans le tue des
cours de l'offre
[Musique]
[Rires]
hoyau voyant quelles sont les nouvelles
d'aujourd'hui odieux que tient fifi la
fourmi a chanté tout l'été
les temps changent autrefois c'était les
cigales qui soit est tous des tgv
tu as chanté tout l'été oui mon cher
je suis devenu une grande vedette de
music hall j'ai des fans
je donne des autographes je suis une
star d'aidé qui doit en faire une tête
le public n'aime plus eagle elle chante
toujours la même source et toi qu'est ce
que tu chantes tu yuko les doux pas mon
tube ben on écoute j'ai suivi la forme
et j'ai la phobie fatigue oui oui oui
qui quitte ainsi fi à favoris alors sa
valeur ce nom et sa balance au betis et
rue de moi en font qu il connaît
décidément bien la musique malien et la
célèbre vedette fifi la fourmi rentrer
chez elle j'ai suivi la fabrication d'un
faux billets a dit oui mais il suffirait
formé à bien des ennuis
c'est vrai j'ai chanté tout l'été mais
personne n'est venu m'écouter et
maintenant ma maintenant j'ai plus rien
à manger
je vais mourir de faim j'avais la forme
et elle fait bien mal parti cependant à
l'atelier des frères caster tout le
monde s'inquiétait de ce que devenait
suffit d'informer ses missions asseyez
et ya donc un succès on peut très bien
vivre sans la gloire
oui mais on ne peut pas vivre sans
manger cfi vraiment n'a plus d'appétit
si elle ne chante plus mais elles
dansent devant le buffet pourquoi parce
qu'il est vide son méfait noms d'avocats
le groupe hli l1 fait l'effort me sens
très orgueilleuse comment faire pour
l'empêcher de mourir de fer et des mois
j'ai eu l'idée d'y bible on va en gagner
les lieux fait mais pour qu'une fête
soit une fête
il faut une vedette une grande vedette
et c'est ainsi que
vie en vue que dans ce bris je veux bien
accepté de chanter pour votre petite
fête
mais je veux un contrat signé par tout
le monde
pq laure arripe dip je suis une vedette
très cher
ton prix s'emballent notre bon alors je
veux 3 kg de mouches san devenir miss o
et c'est un prix d'ami quelques jours
plus tard je vais vous interpréter mon
grand succès la fourme et sacchi
oui je suis un fou rire oui oui oui oui
il qui je suis et la remercie mes habits
merci je vais vous annoncer une grande
nouvelle
je redoute les scènes m'ont ouais parce
que je n'ai aucun talent je n'ai jamais
été une grande vedette je vous ai tous
menti et sans vous je serai porte saint
mais si mais si je vous le quittez notre
forêt j'ai le temps je vous jure que je
ne repartirai du jamais vu depuis sa
venue
merci mes amis et maintenant j'avais
tout le monde et d'idées
de mémoire de hibou ce fut la plus jolie
fait qu'on n'ait jamais vu dans notre
chère forêt syfy la fourmi pu dire
qu'une fois dans sa vie elle avait eu un
gros succès de sauteuses à bientôt chère
fille fan
et puis pour une prochaine édition de
notre petit écho de la forêt